[Music]
hey everybody episode 5 Nick America
thanks for being here and thanks for
still being here if you're new thanks
for joining this is a podcast about my
exploration into my ethnic roots my my
immigrant roots where I come from how
I'm here why I'm here and how I've dealt
with all that and process that growing
up it's funny every time you think you
figured things out about like your
upbringing or who you are you know every
five years you wake up and go oh I was
wave [ __ ] wrong about that my 20s I
realized my teen years were just a cloud
of just confusion nonsense anger
depression all that stuff and then my
late 20s I've felt differently about my
teen years it was maybe a little bit
more fun than allowed myself to have I
woke up to the realization that I was
burying a lot of my ethnic you know
heritage and identity and pride and all
that sort of stuff in order to fit in
you know I didn't really have a an Arab
community 11-news community where I live
which I found through only you know four
or five episodes so far but those things
make a difference you know I've talked
to people who grew up with like an
Indian community or like a Mexican
community and it really helped you know
define them it helped shape - they are
and gave them some some sense of pride
and I didn't have a lot of that I had
that in the home for sure my parents
were always you know be proud of who you
are be proud of where we come from
everything in Lebanon low is better than
anything you know that we could eat and
wear or see and all that sort of stuff
you know they didn't mean it a lot of
the time but they just wanted to remind
us but and now now I'm
thirty's and I'm kind of like you know
you see your parents getting older and
you know you're starting to become like
your mid-thirties you're like what do I
want to hold on to what do I want to
reclaim what do I want to figure out and
anything is better late than never
you know it's kind of scary sometimes to
to just to see what you've kind of put
on the back burner you know so to speak
or just really kind of hid from people
and from yourself and then now to wake
up and go I got to do this before it's
too late
and this is that effort this is that
effort to have those discussions with
other people and learn about myself and
learn about them and hopefully share
those experiences with anyone willing to
listen so here we are
episode 5 before we get into that
wrapping up a weekend here or a week at
Lake Tahoe headlining the improv
a few of you came out or at least made
it made me aware that you came out so
thanks anyone else who came to a show
appreciate it love you let's see I'm
going home for a little bit and then
I'll be in I'll be in San Francisco
headlining the San Francisco punchline
July 6th 7th and 8th you can get tickets
on through my website or at the
punchlines website come to those shows
man San Francisco rocks that Club is one
of the best I recorded my last album
there 1982 which if you haven't heard
that get it somewhere Spotify Apple
music you can buy it on iTunes if you
want to give me some money you can buy
it on vinyl if you want to give me some
money and have a record hot pink vinyl
limited edition get your hands on it
also my first one there's still some
copies of those too so go ahead and do
that all that's at Nick Youssef calm and
then later in July I'll be at the Tempe
improv with Bobbie Lee and oh you know
what I completely blanked on this um
I'll be in New York again New York City
June Oh
eivin's through the 19th i'll just be
doing a bunch of spots around at the
clubs around town so i will post those
as I kind of have them they kind of roll
in as as I go along it kind of works
like Los Angeles where you just leave as
ales you know and then you kind of gets
boxed as the days or as that week shows
up so I don't have specifics right now
but I'll be at the stand I'll be at New
York Comedy Club and then I'll play
specific nights and whatever other shows
come up so if you live in New York come
out to a show say hi and there we go so
this episode friend of mine Raj Desai
we've known each other for many many
years this easily one of the most
in-depth conversations we've ever had
his friends he just got back from
writing for the White House
Correspondents Dinner that Hasan Minhaj
from The Daily Show hosted who I hope to
get on the show too he was busy last
time I was in New York but maybe this
time maybe when I'm out there I'll be
able to grab him for a quick hour but
Raj wrote on the Correspondents Dinner
and if you haven't seen it google it
it's on it's on YouTube it's great Sun
does a great job to some great jokes in
there Raj decides responsible for a
bunch of them so we talked about that
experience you know having basically
three you know Indian dudes like ethnic
guys that are not your you know
run-of-the-mill white Christian males
writing for a show like this you know so
we talked about that experience and then
we get into you know a few different
conversations one of which was an
interesting one about his view on every
time he sees you know an Indian person
on TV it's still like amazing to him
that that they've been you know sort of
like accepted and put on TV and in film
and you know in western media even
though it's happening more he grew up
with the idea of it that's not something
you see you know and that's a weird
thing you know if you're not from a
background like that to sit there and go
to see some you know something that
you're a part of like not represented
really in any way
growing up you know now more so for sure
you know these younger kids are I'm
going to have it a lot different in a
great way you know they'll grow up
seeing a little bit of everything on TV
and on the internet and you know media
assist there's so many different
subgenres now that you can kind of see
whatever you want you know maybe not in
movies and on you know major TV programs
yet but we're getting there
see he talks about what that was like
and his upbringing in Dallas Texas which
I was I didn't know that I thought he
grew up in the East Coast somewhere or
something so we get into you know was
there an Indian community there what was
that like
what was your home life school all that
sort of stuff how did you navigate the
waters and not the middle of Texas being
in an Indian kid and then some adulthood
stuff you know he he was a lawyer for a
while he's very political we avoid
politics for the most part so you know
it's not going to turn into like and
another thing about the president blah
blah blah so very good very thoughtful
conversation Rogers a very smart guy
very funny guy and you can connect with
him on online if you want to tell him
how I talked about the episode and
definitely find him online and read his
I read some of the writing he's done he
has a tumblr Raj Desai ra J and then
last name des AI you can find his tumblr
and links to his um his essays and
things he's written for The New Yorker
he has a great piece on dating and then
he I think just published something with
McSweeney's - which is a great satirical
humor site to check that out follow them
on Twitter at Raj Desai and let them
really think and let me know what you
think of these episodes any questions
comments thoughts concerns contact at
Nick Youssef calm or
Nik America pot at gmail.com and and
yeah let's talk tell me who you'd like
to hear on here tell me what subjects
you'd like to hear discuss you know all
that stuff let's uh let's trade notes to
make this podcast good better by the day
so I'm going to continue enjoying this
sweet-ass view of Lake Tahoe on my last
day here and then I'll be back in Los
Angeles may 24th my next new material
show at The Comedy Store 8 p.m. really
good lineup Sean cotton Neal Brennan
Graham Elwood Jeff Harris myself and a
few others and blanking on the names and
I'll be doing some spots around town at
the Comedy Store and elsewhere so we'll
see you out there see you in New York
very soon and see you next week on Nick
America okay so welcome back to
California oh yeah thank you thank you
yeah how was writing for the
Correspondents Dinner I feel like it got
a like way more press than usual right
it seemed that way I mean we all were
thought that it could either be a big
yawn like no one would pay attention
because the president wasn't there or
because of Sam B's thing yeah but I
think because he wasn't there it
actually caught a lot more attention
yeah and then the other aspect that you
know I thought about hindsight was we
are talking to a roomful of people cover
the news I'd be interested yes
transpired but you know like do you know
who hosted it last year I the same
position yeah and I'm like a your
political John McLaughlin junkie I'm a
comedy head you're a comedy had waited a
day so it can be a big yawn a lot of
years was it it wasn't Trevor Noah
wasn't no [ __ ] who did host it last
year's it was Larry Wilmore but I didn't
know until I looked it that's what I'm
saying like I find it it does just kind
of go into the ether and you yeah you
read some of the jokes in an article and
your hands are funny and you move on so
this one that's kind of what I think we
actually all assumed it would be more
like and it actually
yeah I'm not sure I think it's because
Trump wasn't there it caught a lot more
attention and he held that rival rally
that drew listen to it
so I think yeah and it was also the
first one about in his presidency so
they're not I think people were going to
be like wool what's this person gonna
get a day and then because you know you
would tune into Trump's reaction the net
if he had or whatever his tweets were
going to be about it um yeah that is
interesting and I guess like how much
would they make fun of him you know yeah
I think it was also like what was the
tone going to be and all that kind of
stuff and I have to say like um you know
Hudson he he worked incredibly I mean
really insanely hard but he also played
it really smartly he turned down all the
jokes about like hair and tiny hands yep
good there were not all that none of
that that he was like I don't want that
stuff he didn't want anything about
Trump being attracted to his daughter
any of the stuff that come even comic
writers think is funny yeah Trump he
just he was like let's talk about him
and what he's doing and yeah we think
about him not about I mean this jokes
have also been like done to death dad
they have I mean you know and and so
that that's part of it I'm sure why but
he wanted something cohesive at they
told a story and brought himself into it
and he he did no I don't think he did a
ton of the brick and mortar like joke
writing but the themes were all his and
really so his decision to go after the
media yes yeah that was my favorite part
I think it was it was it I mean it was I
that's great I mean I think it was a
great part of it and I think he yeah he
him and maybe the head writer too
III don't know exactly who came with I
was just sort of told well this is this
is the theme we're going for right jokes
about it you know you have various
section so I guess I don't know who
exactly but he had to have had a lot to
do with who's the head writer
prashanta Venga tech he writes for Bill
Nye saves the world and look I was one
of
on that so and he's a stand-up as well
but God doesn't do a ton anymore I don't
think so but yeah they they kind of came
up with a great great theme yeah and did
they use a bunch of Daily Show writers
like I would assume they'd bring they
did it was mostly mostly Daily Show
people okay I think ultimately yeah and
then any other like can I mention like
big names that kind of pop in and be
like hey I'm gonna help out i dad I may
not be able to talk about just because I
could no one told me I could but there
were big names who who lent a hand at
the hand I was like um you know we like
review the script overall and said okay
fashion assist cuz it is such a big deal
thing you know like you wonder like if
they just like pass it by as many people
as possible I think he did I think he
passed by and you know you know without
giving too much away you know yeah
obviously he was on The Daily Show so
there's a lot of people from that world
who had done this before so yeah pretty
much everybody who done it before from
that yeah world that's how is it true
that there were a lot of people that
turned it down do you know anything
about that I definitely think it's yeah
true yeah yeah yeah it's a pretty it
wasn't surprising I think when he said
that or other people said you know a lot
of people didn't want to do this like I
could see why they wouldn't but I can
also see why you would want to I guess
so I mean I think the way it turned out
yeah I mean the name I saw in the news
and like the New York Times was James
Corden turned it down you know I don't
know if they said removed have turned it
down so he didn't feel like he would
that would be a good fit for I know now
that a would or wouldn't I would think
that he could seem like that would have
been all hands and hair jokes you but
yeah you know I would be her yeah but he
has I'll be honest I don't watch a ton
of James Corden show but he does he's
not shy about saying he does not like
Donald Trump ya know so I kinda was a
little surprising turn it down maybe it
was just like I'm too busy I Sam you
know it could be a million doesn't have
to be I do this card here he is I got
way too many
luckily I can I do the correspondent
from a car yeah can it all be one
karaoke song yeah about yeah and then
and I do think it was maybe that
Samantha bees rival thing and abuses oh
yeah yeah which that's where all the
buzz was me when I kid an ad they had I
mean the thing I thought that we all
kind of thought was like if you followed
it Samantha bees event had a ton of
celebrities well the White House
Correspondents Dinner had Matthew Modine
and Dean Cain and that was it that's
hilarious
so yeah Will Ferrell was on you know
Samantha you know like a lot of big
people were on it and got up to it so we
kind of thought that's what people would
you know naturally that's a gravitation
and I think it did fine I mean I'm not
saying it didn't do well I heard yeah I
heard it too but it didn't get nearly
the coverage she didn't seem to but
maybe because all the media were like
what we're gonna report on the thing we
attended that could be it via to and
then and I was surprised by how many I
mean have you ever watched one of those
live I never have on correspondent yeah
I've seen a couple over the years
yeah like like back when I had cable and
regular yeah me so low on time and I was
shocked how many people watch it live
and tweeted about it and I was like well
that sounds like a great set I'm here
like you have nothing recorded a night
yeah like I was kind of shocked you know
that's funny and like I said I'm at you
and I are both comic heads and you know
you know political junkies in wet yet I
would probably never tuned into it live
you know yeah I don't think I mean
unless like I was you know sitting
somewhere writing or something and then
like you know they do the live feeds on
Twitter of certain things yeah yeah and
because that's one thing a lot of comics
do or kind of did more a few years ago
is when something would be on it live
tweet it yeah yeah so I would do it
maybe for that yeah because I got myself
over the years watching [ __ ] like the
Golden Globes and me do that yeah just
so you know yeah in jokes it
but yeah I would never just do that for
the [ __ ] of it right I mean you know I
was uh but I think maybe people like in
the last year or just becoming more
politically engaged so maybe they were
like I'm gonna watch the Correspondents
Dinner and because I'm watching more of
the news in general and reading the
paper more yeah yeah ever it is so and I
will say this I mean I I can speak a
little bit about it which is that you
know he is like he is you know Muslim so
that probably meant if you're Muslim
American you're probably just interested
what is it I going to do and say and he
is you know South Asian I was
immediately interested in the fact that
he got it you know yeah I know him a
little personally obviously but you know
just the kind of thing where you know if
you're from certain communities and
someone it's it's not that often they
get high-profile stuff that's true so
those people okay it was news in India
you know because Wow
and which isn't shocking if you're you
know because it's you know it is a
relatively well-known gig right yeah in
the in the given year yeah so it was it
was I wouldn't be shocked if a lot of
the views came on saying the you to
whatever the view count is yes a lot of
them came from outside the country yeah
associated has 900 million view whatever
like a lot of Americans watch that yeah
exactly so I wouldn't be shot because it
was it was significant yeah the people
from so was it like exciting for you to
like do it because of the like personal
connection you know it was at first I
was excited about it for that for a
little bit but I kind of thought of it
is you know a little bit of like a
run-of-the-mill or standard joke writing
you know about whatever the subject
which is happened to be Donald Trump for
CNN or whatever and then as it got
closer and closer I started to see that
you know frankly even my parents were
pretty interested in proud of it that I
was working on something that was a
little high profile for yeah you know
Indian American which I am as well and I
did feel a very I can tell you I cared a
lot about it because I was so nervous
before it happened and I wasn't relieved
until the reviews yeah it took a couple
days to feel a sense of relief even when
it was done I was like what's happening
online you know right right there's no
satisfaction nowadays yeah because we
did to get went pretty well in the room
but then it then the question is how are
people receiving it out there and do
people even care you know was this not
right did the media uh that whole chunk
on the media was that well-received in
the room or what did did sections go oh
the USA Today people go like well we
don't like this well you know what it's
I feel like I mean I feel like it was
mostly if you got a third of the room to
laughs maybe it's similar to some clubs
or something you know it's good enough
it's a lot of fun on TV but it will
definitely clammed up about laughing at
other media organizations because
they're all worked together the allness
together you know and I think it's a
question we ask ourselves quite a bit in
the process which is like well if we
make fun of of anything even if it's a
joke about Donald Trump tweeting is it
okay it would Jake Tapper or someone
like that laugh at it because then are
they showing their lack of impartiality
or something you know what I mean right
and then and I do fine you mention
yesterday day because we kind of open
with a couple of you and we kind of
thought that was like a topic everybody
likes to make fun of but it was not that
was well-received as I thought just
because I think people don't want to
laugh the colleagues to their face and
yeah you know that'll be taken the next
day at work exactly or I I mean I did I
get where they're coming from right like
you know so I I do think the stuff that
was not about the media did better for
sure and the stuff you know even the
stuff that we're you know you know it
made fun of himself a little bit you
know that all that did really well and
then he kind of made fun of missing
admit you know Sean Spicer was an easy
top for whatever reason they all love
making fun Sean Spicer even though they
worked with him you know
yeah um I guess he's just such a funny
you know he's just such a what a bizarre
thing he's the press secretary you know
what he says and what comes out his
mouth so yeah I mean that's all it was
but um so I I do think they kind of did
clam up a little
during the media stuff you know and
there was a huge groan we made fun it
was joke I wrote actually made fun of
Huffington Post and people groan and I
was like The Huffington Post like it's
like right it's a reblog all the work
most of you do that you have some
original work yeah but if you cannot
make fun of the Huffington Post
it doesn't make fun of you know like on
it and if you aren't on the side of like
a fan not anti having a post but it's
just like they're literally taking your
work yeah and you know aren't you
annoyed and we can't make fun of them
and I got this massive groan the joke
was that they are not in fact a
journalistic organization we were saying
some pretty negative things yeah I mean
yeah but I still you know you think
everybody would be able to but I guess
when you go in and tensions are high
like we got to be careful yeah yeah then
the second you attack anybody they
discover oh yeah yeah and I get right a
little bit he ran these jokes you know
60 plus times he only had about three
weeks run up that's a lot of sets you
know yeah all at the comedy sellers so
the other concern was the Comedy Cellar
you know I don't know if I've been in
I've never done it maybe on it have been
in it but it's like it's you know the
comedy story you know it's like probably
a younger audience then who's at the I
can almost guarantee it's a hottie is at
the white house quote so that becomes a
question - it's like well are they just
older and maybe a little more uptight
are they older and maybe just don't get
references to certain things right
whatever we had a reference to call of
duty or that type of thing you know yeah
so that was a concern too was like the
sort of overall mean age and everything
so
but I think it went about as well as if
you go in my opinion yeah you know I
guess I'm impartial or partial but you
know that's cool yeah I like that I like
the approach that he had like not going
F not going for the you know cheap shots
yeah yeah and making like having like a
message and a theme and yeah yeah but I
mean he's kind of that guy you know like
his stand-up is very like thoughtful it
is you know and even his correspondence
pieces on the daily show ya know like
just like that's yeah
that's his approach to comedy and it
makes them like unique and stuff that's
cool it was it was it like a minority
heavy writing staff today I go in that
direction or there was he he did you
know make an attempt to do that
yeah I think ultimately the the daily
show people were were pretty were pretty
big part of them you know and as far as
I know none of them were mine there was
couple females you know but okay as far
as I know there weren't any minorities
so they were the majority of the writing
staff I think so okay yeah I don't know
you know there was there was definitely
multiple you know of Asian people mean
being one of them and you know I'm gonna
turn this into a Daily Show writing gig
did he come on it's right right the
staff in you yeah yeah well I learned to
be like he basically had the writing
staff and you're like here's how [ __ ]
hack it isn't like we need well I didn't
either thing is like I've known him for
a long time apparently so it wasn't
totally done like you know did you know
we did connect and then okay I ended up
doing it and and at first I was just
going to do it kind of as a friend thing
like you know here I can write some I
think I can do a good job in this do you
want some jokes and then started and he
said sure and then he said why are you
just cool partake you know and the whole
thing and doing it though so it yeah it
was a it may have been the thing that
I'm most proud of I've done my entire
comedy career you know up to right like
two
up till now and just you know if I I
mean if I stay in it for twenty years it
might be the thing I'm most yeah and why
wouldn't you then because this'll lead
it the next thing I mean that when you
wrote on triumph yeah I'm sure in some
way helped lead to this what I think it
did I think it quite a bit actually I
mean this'll lead to something else yeah
in a year you'll be living in New York
writing for The Daily Show yeah yeah who
knows but I mean I do think yeah I think
it was very it's felt kind of mean we
you started comedy before me but the I
start in 2005 and the idea that someone
who looked like me would host the why I
was great I you were taught us did you
crazy that'll never happen
this business doesn't work like that
looks funny and [ __ ] oh five there
weren't really there were obviously
minority conveniens I mean well I know
yeah obviously but but I feel like they
always just had one of each for the most
part ed the diverge ad or like you know
it just seemed so you know I don't know
I guess maybe I'm just out of touch I
was even saying it to you know to us in
that writer for Sean it's just kind of
like I find this mind-blowing and maybe
to you the two of you it's just like
yeah but of course why wouldn't you
expect this you know I don't know
they're all so younger than me it's a
little like um I guess about a little
bit like when Obama ran in 2007 some of
the older but John Lewis for instance
the civil rights legend older was just
like you know ask you know but I'm just
going to support every Clinton because
the odds of you it's just not possible
right yeah lack you know nominee from
major party and then eventually of
course they endorsed him and it you know
I think maybe I still live by I don't
know I in show business I said at the
time I thought in 2005 er I thought you
know I'll be lucky to get a writing job
and a couple of TV credits you know I
could ever they're not going to make a
show starring an Indian guy and next
thing you know there's like whatever you
know is either show and all right so
what about when hit what about his rise
in
stand-up was that kind of like wow this
is so cool or was it surprising or I
guess it was a little surprising I did
think it was cool
I did find it surprising I guess and I
did feel a little like maybe you know I
felt like it was you know quote good for
everybody in that community right or but
then at the same time there's this other
theory that goes around about you know
minorities and stuff in any business you
know if the door opens the 1 and people
feel like what we did art we checked off
our list Sarah and like the choking yeah
I don't like being on one know that when
do you think another black president is
going to be possible I don't know could
be next time I don't know yeah it's also
other factors like who VI candidness NAB
but like you know it's like actually a
Malcolm Gladwell piece about about that
about how like and he used the example
of a female who was led into like the
National Arts Council or something on in
written in like 1890 and then another
one wasn't let in for like another 50
years the response when it was welcome
you don't and it was well we let her and
there we did that you know so there is
some maybe there was a little bit I
don't I don't know what I at the time I
just thought wow well people will
consider you a comedian if you yeah
aren't you know beautifly yeah yeah
exactly and I guess I thought it was a
benefit I think it has benefited people
of all Kyle is you know I think I mean
that theory I feel like maybe would have
applied before like social media in the
internet I think which unfortunately I'm
that old I started well I guess myspace
but which it was bear I mean now yeah
yeah but I do think I think your point
of like so let's say if you're talking
about something like who Comedy Central
would give a special to there would
probably just be one yeah maybe two
black guys yeah two women
and maybe one you know of another type
of yeah that's about it yeah you know
and they did have they did seem to I
mean I guess I'm saying something
negative about the arguably negative
about the in December which is at that
time it did seem like they had a you
know bucket system or whatever you want
to call it where it was like okay we
checked off her box for this this and
this and the rest goes to you know and
I'm sure it had to do with what they
thought was marketable you know what I
thought was yeah honey making a head
because the moment it isn't that will
change the moment it isn't it makes
sense to have different you know
minority groups represented of course
they're going to do it financially you
know so I don't think it's anything like
inherently races I think it's just what
they were used to what they thought but
I did feel like I don't know if you
would feel the same way I I felt like I
was competing into people who are just
like me
and that was who I was competing for for
once Lots it's the East in stand up yeah
that's how I felt because the fact that
like I mean it's sort of implied in like
you know the way the programs are
structured like the fact that they're
even our programs let they have we have
a diversity programs you go alright so
now I'm competing against every other
Arab or Indian rock or whatever you are
yeah and then there's one slot or two
slots yeah you go okay yeah and then I
guess you know there's resentment built
by people like before you even show your
work they go like to diversity hire like
that was also very talented exactly yeah
so I don't know I I the more I the more
I think about you know my relationship
to showbiz and etc with terms of my
ethnicity I guess I I have more negative
things to say about it and positive
family from what I feel like but there's
no way to really know so who knows and
then it is hard sometimes the pinpoint
overt racism over sponsor and you rarely
hear like we want to bring in any Indian
so you never hear that have you're never
here you know
and what like so one one thing that's
interesting that you may have noticed it
was even your own like auditioning
whatever is like so Nickelodeon and
Disney Channel they're really they have
a lot of diverse University in their
programming right now because those kids
are growing up in a way more diverse
America right so like for Disney or Nick
Nick alone I don't know both of them
I've been called into play like
something that really had nothing to do
characters name was like Robert or
whatever I was a teacher or whatever I
was like this is cool yeah interesting
you know you want a [ __ ] cab driver
or like a I owned an Indian restaurant
absolutely yeah it's great so I do think
that that that must that's gonna change
it it must be changing and someone like
Aziz has changed it yeah does play like
he did played a guy named Tom Haverford
and exactly AK and even his stand up
there's no accent he's gone hip-hop and
yeah he's doing like what any other if
you heard just audio you'd be like yeah
that's some white kid Chicago or
Brooklyn or wherever absolutely and I
think that I don't know because in my I
never wore like it's obvious from if
you're relatively familiar with any you
know culture you'll know from my first
name yeah at least the way it's spelled
Raj that I'm Indian right but yeah I
never wore it on my sleeve in my act or
anything it wasn't anything deliberate
not to I don't I could spend hours
wondering why you're talking about it
and what's over here did I know and I
have spent hours wondering I'm thinking
about it okay let's go into like we are
like your formative years I guess did
you at any point have issues with your
name when you're like I'd rather go by
the name Robert or Ron or any other look
a lot of kids do that you know what I
was mildly lucky cuz Raj sounds like
Roger right so my full name is Rajan Raj
and yeah and if it was it's not hard
people to say Raj right
you know I'm non-union people right so I
I was a little lucky in that department
I never had I know people who have had
plenty of identities you know but I
never I wouldn't say I personally did I
think that um
I grew up in moved all over when I was a
really young I don't really remember it
but I basically spent my life in
Tennessee and Texas well part of
Tennessee outside Chattanooga town
called Dixon I mean that was like two
years of my life that I remember I was
like six and seven I remember pretty
well and then after that it was all
Texas and very - so unlikely places that
I would never think like what led your
family to go we're going to Chattanooga
1012 where my dad got a job he's an
engineer and look I got a job there same
thing with with Texas so and where did
you where did your parents grow up both
both grew up in India Laurel India as
well not even like urban India and so
they grew up there and then my dad came
here in 63 yeah to go to college he had
a master's degree
and then he went back in he got married
and the plan was for you know my mom to
join him and have you know start a
family here and then possibly moved back
to India was he not into the American
chicks in college my dad well I mean
there was no there was no dating for
that generation he was going to get
married to whoever his parents wanted
him to basically wait and really even
like even moving to the states and like
with the assumption like I'm gonna live
here it was like okay you can go to
college in America but you got to come
back here and get married because we
still control that aspect of your life
yeah I don't know if it was that I mean
some of this stuff isn't even verbal
it's just like expected you know and
okay but I think if my dad had met I
mean I do know people of my dad's
generation who met somebody off you're
not even Indian you know and married
them and it was fine you know yeah maybe
if you had someone I think that the idea
of dating for my my dad I'm sure it was
just not something that crosses mine I
know it sounds a mind-blown no no not at
all like my parents are
the same way they there wasn't the
concept of dating yes we didn't know it
exactly
didn't that didn't exist and and even
that affected me some because I didn't
date until I was in column or in general
yeah in that aspect and held you know
I'm uh forty oh wow well I guess that's
good definitely uh yeah um okay so he
went back so it was basically an
arranged marriage yeah okay yeah yeah
yeah and and are they still together now
they are I mean what I always say about
arranged marriage is that you know a
good chunk of them work out really well
I've read I read a study about that yeah
and I was found it kind of fascinating
because your average relationship
doesn't last
half the people he's in America get
divorced oh yeah no one can make
anything work and so many arranged
marriages work and there is by large to
almost strangers right they're vetted by
the families I mean I practically
strangers I would say this is only
nineteen sixties India I would say India
now the culture is to give people a
chance to know each other a little bit
it's more like setting someone up you
know like yeah but say I know this
person and your parents are basically
tinder though essentially yeah
yeah it exactly our radius locations
here though so yeah yeah yeah this girl
so I mean that is more what it's more
quote-unquote reasonable now back then
it was this is yeah here's your here's
your future can I throw out a name for
the Indian dating service um I
there is one to call tandoori because it
should be yeah yeah I got a suggestion
yeah okay yes um that would that would
that would leave Adam sure
sell that someone or something to steal
announcer it um ok though so they would
basically set set it up and then you
would just go meet your dad just
basically met your mom like yeah and I
think you know in like the 80s or 90s
more like hey these are three or four
choices which one do you prefer
okay and then now it's more long as I
considered like crazy progressive I
think that's all it's all it's all like
baby steps to the point where you know
in my family people married outside our
race and right a big deal anymore there
was some time when it was and yeah you
know the truth is is that people will
always choose I mean young people in
India want choice you're like you do or
I do right so people I don't know
anybody who that I'm that I know plenty
of any people born here who are like you
know what I just want to marry whoever
my dad's nobody said that right people
always move towards choice and I think
our parents my parents and they get that
because no one would choose to be told
that that bad yeah I don't use no choice
exactly nobody would write like this
it's part of the culture here like the
identity of the average American is your
individual you do what you want and
that's what we you know urge everyone
yeah okay what's yours do your own way
no yeah and I think that that's a big
friction with Indian families that the
generation above mine is more like you
know we're a family unit everything is
done to advance the family unit yeah I'm
here you're taught you're out the door
18 yeah you you're not out of the family
except for the last they do and
dismissal like when I was 16 I worked at
Pizza I just gave the money to my
parents believe it or not yeah it's not
like they needed the money this is how I
told my friends and they looked at me
like I was some outer space so I was
like well no it's just what we do I
don't know it just goes to the family
income and I didn't think anything of it
until I was really get any of it back
like dad I mean
a hundred dollars this weekend is like
here's 20 well no I mean he he also
bought me everything
yeah clothes and whatever you know it
was just like yeah this just goes so did
your friends in any way like sort of
convince you to like try and get that
money back or were you just like no no
no that's the way it is I don't want to
hear I'm not there's no discussion I
think that they didn't convince no they
were just like what a bizarre thing why
don't you want to keep it why don't you
want to spend it and yeah well no I just
still just go to it's not wasn't a ton
of money but it would go to college or
whatever you know or whatever was was
needed I didn't think anything of it you
know it's it's it does sound crazy when
I say I would not expect my kids do that
if they worked a summer job or something
yeah so yeah it's their money for where
the hell yeah right what you'd kind of
like in a way encourage it's like a
you're earning money you know what that
process is like and get the value of it
and yeah maybe be wiser about spending
it because it wasn't handed to you by
your dad or no yeah my dad was actually
really some of the things he did it was
the smartest thing he did was he said
get a job in food service because you do
realize how much it sucks and you'll
want want to do it and he was right
that's how that is actually very sorted
yeah that's really funny because I
wanted to work it and my dream was to
work at Blockbuster Video and get for my
dream but I was 16 cars no I know that's
funny yeah it's just it's funny on
multiple levels now because there's just
one of the lots of you know videos right
there I knew one guy that worked there
he said he got seven three rentals a
week I was like that's why I could watch
seven million Harry that's actually now
sixteen year old me's dream - yeah l75
Louis including video games yeah
probably yeah Jesus so I was like that's
what I wanted but I think though I mean
off subject but I think it was actually
pretty competitive to get a gig it I
would run that reason I'd yeah because
it was like I would think so I guess a
cool job for a 16 year old yeah like
yeah working somewhere with that rents
movies and video games or when they were
arcade looking at arcade one yeah there
were jobs where you're like cuz it would
make you in a way more popular even at
school yeah yeah words like dude let's
be nice
to him we'll get the new Resident Evil
game dad and yeah you're probably not
cleaning toilets and taking out trash
today we probably are to some degree but
not the same as yeah not as like a
McDonald yes we're yeah so we're humming
what was the indian population like or
what was the minority population like in
and where was it Arlington Arlington
Texas is regular Piazza if you don't
know it it's where the Dallas Cowboys
play with six Rangers plays yeah it goes
pretty large suburb now of the Dallas
Fort Worth area uh-huh basically in back
then so when I was going up it was I
would say there were some Latinos and
some small percentage maybe if I was a
semi his whole class was about 650
people look like today for a high school
right um it's probably on the my
graduating class rather the high school
itself this was like right I got it
okay um there were three onions there
were two Union people on me and one
other guy maybe like 20 feet and there's
there's a now is very sizable Vietnamese
American population at the time it was
starting to get that way and then maybe
like 30 black people and like 30 Latinos
so maybe a hundred tops out of 650 we're
not white yeah so people were familiar
with minorities yeah somewhat yeah yeah
but I mean I guess any evening kids were
very low it was only two of us yeah
graduating class so so it was definitely
I think the more I think about it it was
a huge that growing up that way was
probably very impactful on me you know
and there's so many ways what was like
if you could think of like one of the
big things that kind of sticks out as
like wow I didn't grow up in Arlington
Texas I wouldn't be like this or that or
or I wish I had more access to because
if there was an Indian community maybe
that would have who knows what that
would have done they brought you closer
to the to your roots and that kind of
thing because that cultural identity
thing what the people I've talked to
that grew up somewhere with a good
whatever it is population or more tied
to their roots more proud you know he's
got a language better
all that sort of stuff I think that's
very true so I think I think for me you
know one thing it pride made me was a
lot more you know it's a term Union
people use is like more westernized more
Americanized right just whitewashed when
I watch that I mean I don't love to say
it but probably some people would say
I'm a very white in person I get that
about about yourself yeah and I don't
know what to make of it because it's not
like white people think I'm white you
know your place to be we're like and I
have me I'm I look I can pass for a lot
of different things you could ya even
assume cuz cuz I'm so like white yeah or
whatever the term is that isn't weird
about that term for me but um look the
way I dress I've no accent and like you
know I'm fair-skinned if it's not very
summer and yeah yeah um so some people
just think I'm [ __ ] white yeah
so see if they don't know my last name
and it's sort of like the shock to them
and I go yeah but in my head I'm not a
lot of the time when I go visit my
family I'm not I'm not at all I mean I I
guess I once had a conversation with
someone Riley's Chinese right is like
it's so it's so in my DNA that it's
almost even hard to it's almost part of
everything I do that I it's like innate
and I can't even explain it you know how
what kind of influence growing up in an
Indian household was right now just so
look would religion behind really we
were not that religious we are Hindu you
know so you know we were not that
religious my dad as a scientist I think
he yeah wouldn't come out and say
everybody probably basically things
religion is stupid you know so we were
not that what about your mom what'd she
do she she worked as a sort of medical
tech she worked for a pathology labs
it's a Java Web site Oh technologists
like that is a chemical engineer so he
is one else
yeah household / yeah yeah and go
yeah but my grandparents were very
religious and and I don't eat meat it's
not necessarily totally really just more
cultural I would say almost but so I do
think so
just in general culturally Indians don't
eat well so we're so one thing I'd say
that's that's totally fine is if people
don't get but like it's a India's a
little like I mean Mexico's like this
well you know it was a bunch of cultures
forced together by the British right
higher so our culture the Desai's we're
from a state in a sort of a group of you
called Gujaratis on a state called
Gujarat so like Patel that pata a lot of
people know that last name that's a good
jarate last name sai is a lot of Methos
m eh ta those people tend not to have
eaten meat for centuries
Wow that particular group beef is a very
common one that Hindus donee right but
the vegetarian is very common across the
across the whole country but I think
what sometimes that people don't even
like like um people don't always get
that it's it's not a monolithic culture
it's actually a lot of different
cultures that were again like kind of
[ __ ] either that is becoming more
monolithic just like America is because
of you know national TV easily and all
this kind of culture that it is
pervading everybody but but my parents
grew up pretty isolated from from from
large cities you know so they they they
did retain a lot more of that culture
yeah and you know I do think so yeah I
think it had a big effect on me I
haven't totally unpacked at all I
growing up there and then what that
meant but was what I mean somewhere like
Texas I mean like I'm so you know a part
of you surprised like meat isn't on the
flag yeah I mean it was definitely and
is [ __ ] everywhere right I mean yeah
you are in are you well I think it might
to my parents credit somewhat they said
once I was like a little that they could
do whatever you want I did eat meat you
know basically you know and I think
personally did
where'd you go would you do aa hamburger
I think and I think a choice a lot of it
someone probably was a little bit of why
I don't want to have to draw
are you tired answering questions about
it you know especially when it's in LA
you tell you a vegetarian it's like who
it you know not who isn't but it's very
no one asked you that much about it or
looks at you skeptics yeah but in if
anything are they just like I've gotta
know yeah they were authorized right oh
man oh yeah yeah so but in in that at
that time intent you know if you said it
it was like some people took it like
offensive almost no you mean so it just
was easier to do it almost um so that
would be a way it sort of like because
if you grew up out here to push to like
do something so you're just like leave
me alone
yeah I wouldn't have you know and I had
no like Solidaire either say in my
community of like you know whatever if
there were 15 kids at my high school
maybe I could feel more like yeah you
know we could I could not do that but
it'd be like back off and throw potatoes
yeah yeah yeah yeah I mean so I do think
it was like um I always wonder about it
or what effect it had on me I mean you
can tell you speak very formally right I
if you heard my voice but I I do think
that a lot of young Indian men in the
American men in particular basically
choose on some level to be a white
Indian person or a black Indian person
oh really
some well I think a lot of East Asian
young men do it too yeah where do they
become huge hip hop fans they maybe take
on an accent it isn't their natural
accent yeah and then there's some of us
who just go well I guess I'll just sound
like a newscaster or you know whatever
you know I guess I took that route yeah
yeah like early on er did you have a
phase in high school where you're like
I'm getting in a gangster rap oh no I
mean I do I am a somewhat of rapping but
I may be more to you I was I was
interested in rock and roll yeah I say
that's a Texas thing too
yeah yeah I was are you country music I
I actually am now I was not growing up
yeah and then you did you come back
into it because you're like those are
more my roots are in some one way or
another I think in some ways yeah I mean
because my high school I would say a
solid third of people my graduating
class wore boots and cowboy had a lot of
trucks you know very into that culture
went to rodeos and what I would say
about those I do think I would love to
say it is that like a small percentage
of people were not nice to me maybe a
little close-minded but the vast
majority of people you might consider
quote-unquote reddit were so nice to me
very welcoming very good you know and I
think at the time if you ask me I would
have thought those people were maybe a
little
whatever backwards or hit clankers and
now I look back I think all those people
were actually really nice people for the
heart and treated me very quite well
there was a was there just like a lot of
curiosity and maybe just jokes that were
made and that sort of thing that maybe
when I was always say there was very
little curiosity I would say there was
almost none people James act like you're
like wallpaper I think the thing about
being maybe you feel this way I've heard
to put this way or just like you feel
like you're invisible and very you stick
out like a sore thumb at the same time
based on being a very small minority at
a you know during your formative years
you know so I did feel that way I think
that so there was no cure delightful for
sure who were a handful I would say the
kind of more studious nerdy types were
interested and yeah you know in our
culture and food and that type of thing
and then where I grew up and what going
to India was like you know right
a lot of the teachers were actually
there also adults oh and me yeah more
but most the kids were you know very
uninterested which is totally okay it's
almost better than being uh I guess
disinterested or like upset with you for
being different like why are you here
like I mean there is definitely some
there's definitely some right you know
some bullying some races I think it
probably prepared me for stand-up comedy
you know what helps is like you're not
you're not from a place that's
associated with any sort of like
terrorism or evil like you know I hate
to
doesn't have that no it doesn't and the
country doesn't have a bad reputation
and I do think like I do think as time
has gone on and my parents came here
very early in to Indian immigration you
know I think that there's a lot more
positive connotation to being Indian
America than a lot of other yeah groups
you know especially compared to some you
know Muslim Americans obviously or
Arabic you know it just has a way more
positive connotation and sometimes it's
as simple as like oh my god I love that
the saris your you know or I love the
food you know and it's like okay I'll
take it yeah cool switch yeah you know I
think it has gotten way less like out of
this world
Boren and way more normalized ya know
for by some what to do with media and
probably somewhat refer with some people
just you know they know more people like
that they interact with them
yeah like a you got to think like we
were talking about earlier like the
younger generations are they have access
to those things like on their computer
screens at a much younger age you know
like you could look up so much
information about you know the Indian
kid at your school and the food they eat
find actually go find a place like oh
there's a place I can go try this food
or yeah experience you know this art
exhibit at a museum or so yeah
absolutely I'll tell you some my
hometown there was no Indian restaurants
and we at least have to go to Dallas
which is like you know a pretty large
city there was one Indian restaurant
this is like in the 80s
Wow just one just one and we would go
and it would be all Indian people and I
went recently with my parents to one in
Arlington Texas which is you know get
not a super large city but then there's
up there first of all there's like four
choices of restaurant cool when I went
to one and it was mostly white people
and Dallas Cowboys gear I was just
shocked that's hilarion a pleasant way
you know I just was that's awesome fun
could not believe it was the one in
Dallas when you were growing up was it
good
it was pretty good actually what I say
in general is the ones that were started
you know 30 40 years ago whatever we're
usually by someone who had an
inclination to cook right yeah and now
any and food is sort of a thing people
eat in his trendy or whatever looks like
money and sex and a lot of it is bad I
won't go to most in your restaurant yeah
I'm like I would like Middle Eastern
food right a lot of it I'm like dunk it
so I try to Thomas ah yeah yeah yeah
that's what I think most of it's pretty
bad
yeah Jana so I I would never go to a
buffet either have you ever been to
India's restaurant here in in like Los
Feliz Silverlake it's not like we're for
fountain meets sunset I might have I say
the one in LA I kind of like it samosa
house which is a little that ombre oh
there's one in Culver City there's one
in silver like actually decipher they
don't make the other thing about India
is that the cuisine is different all
over like the one when people think of
quote/unquote Indian food is like naan
and saag paneer in these types of
scheria that's all North Indian and it
is it is the tastiest of all the food
and then the other kind its more common
America South Indian food which is dosa
maybe you've heard of that or that's the
other kind that's pry the second best
Indian food but the kind of my parent
you know we ate was was good jarate food
and that was very very vegetable heavy
in lentils and that type of thing you
know me you know yeah it's uh I guess I
maybe I'm not doing my culture proud
it's not it's not the most tasty of the
Indian yeah but I mean you grew up
eating it you're at least group eating
it every day and then at some point my
pant my mom was like oh he gets me to
Ibiza yeah yeah you whatever you want
was that like off limits or how is that
as far as like eating fast food and that
kind of [ __ ] as long as it was
vegetarian would they ever eat out ever
yeah they we they know and actually I
mean my parents eat meat now oh cool
though they they kind of changed my
brother is a huge foodie in general or
whatever yeah he it's all kinds of stuff
so it's actually fortunately kind of
them well I guess for my view
unfortunately it's dying a bit in my
extended family being nominee vegetarian
um mine I guess I'm not really that
offended but I don't really care
thank you I a choice for me but but yeah
I think beef is the main one that you
have to kind of avoid avoid and watch
yeah yeah so that's cool to hear that
you were like largely like accepted and
not treated really like as an outsider
in school because that's another thing
like that because I have these these
these stereotypes to that I grew up with
you know where I put them on other parts
of the country and people where my
assumption remember when I was first
starting to travel and do comedy in
parts of the south of the Midwest or
something I had the assumption that like
there were not a lot of minorities and
if there were they were like you know
lived in other parts of the city and
they were treated differently like there
was a stereotype about white people and
white parts of the country that I held
on to sure cuz I didn't know that I had
not been there I met someone who was
from [ __ ]
wherever Tennessee or Alabama yeah and
then when I started going to these
places and I was like man I feel bad
that I ever thought this was interesting
yeah at least into bigger cities you
know yeah I've never been to like you
know outskirts of some of these towns or
you know it's small towns of 100 [ __ ]
white rednecks that yeah yeah these
stereotypes have to come from somewhere
no I mean look I mean you know I we
definitely had I mean I had some stuff
that happened to me in junior high that
you know I wouldn't even want to talk
about it was pretty pretty little yeah
okay um and then some other stuff is
more like just racial slurs that type of
thing yeah it did happen for sure but I
just like to look back at lease for the
sake of work and think you know 90% of
people at the very least they were like
well who cares right yeah there was
nothing negative you know yeah so yeah
it's important because when you're young
when I was younger I held on to the
handful of things that were bad that
happened they thought this is
represented this entire group but it's
not you know but so the stereotypes
totally come from some way I'm gonna do
but I was like I was surprised at how
how big of a place it occupied in my
head before I'd gone to these parties
and country you know I go and maybe
again it's I don't look that like that
much of a minority but in certain parts
of the country people can tell I'm not
white right and I'll ask ya know but by
and large I was like you know I was
[ __ ] wrong and happy to be wrong oh
yeah no I've because parts of the
country I'm like I've always wanted to
go to and I had this stupid fear in my
head that I was going to be looked at
differently or like treated differently
and you know and and that was carried
over from being a kid and use of Middle
Eastern people being negative and I'm
like man if if I got bullied in school
or people would ask racist questions and
[ __ ] the suburbs of LA the holiday
anything in Texas and I mean yeah and
you would have gotten the same stuff
there too I just think it's I at least
like to note that the majority of people
weren't like that yeah vast majority
know basically young people you might
label rednecks or whatever we're not
like that to me personally yeah yeah but
but there are a couple incidents where
you like you don't even want to like get
into it yeah it's pretty pretty
humiliating bullying and it's just yeah
yeah not worth I guess it this was a
long time ago but does it still occupy a
place in your head were like I think it
I think it I mean it was so humiliating
that I think that it prepared me for
stand-up comedy because nothing seemed
like it could be as humiliating bombing
didn't seem as bad yeah in a weird way
so maybe it was a good thing I also you
know is one guy that billed me pretty
bad I also have a lot of someone mi late
err found out that he was a horrible
family life it and they are rightfully
they're never from a
have you right right right so but it's
so it's hard to you know dump on some
guy who had a frankly worse childhood
than I did you know yeah from like from
what my understanding is so it was
pretty it was pretty pretty it was a
huge thing in my life at the time yeah
it was pretty pretty pretty bad yeah cuz
those times to feel like they're a lot
longer than they are so lightly water
pie wasn't even that was twenty three
weeks tops
yeah but it carries all like it'll like
carry on for the rest of that school
year yeah earlier feels like a goddamn
eternity oh yeah what I'm a twelve
thirteen you know yeah now a whole
calendar you're just yeah and the
believe it on yeah because I remember
having you know issues with people like
and not even you know some of it was
like race-based you know come into the
conversation here and they're like
you're also a [ __ ] towel head or
whatever the [ __ ] uh-huh but it was you
know mostly because I just was
uncomfortable in my own skin and just an
outcast partially because of that from
being even younger were yeah you're
you're you know out it is different like
you have a big nose and you don't look
white and you have a weird last name and
if the [ __ ] food you brought smells
weird and you're weird and you're
different and you're inundated with that
so then that carries over into your
general confidence you know oh yeah I
mean I don't know about you because you
are a very handsome guy but I will say
there's a look very late bloomer biker
shake up I will say like I did feel like
you know if most of the girls my high
school or wide right there when they're
imagining their boyfriend they're not
imagining someone who looks like me and
I felt totally invisible in that regard
which affects your confidence right
absolutely and you can't blame those
girls for thinking that they're
imagining their wedding they're not
they're imagining Troy Aikman they're
not imagining me or what you know so
alright I get it but it does it that was
not great for my confidence you feel
that way at the time now were you as
diplomatic as your no I was not okay
doesn't family yeah we were yeah way
different directions really I understand
that's the way you read like [ __ ] yeah
you know no I was not I don't think I
had the perspective to realize that you
know how did you handle like things like
that what did you like because those
things come out of units are way what
you do have like an angry period or were
you like completely withdrawn or or how
did that work out for you did you get in
a fight sir did you avoid them
completely I avoided fights at all I was
not a tough guy so yeah like was not
going to get into a fistfight with
anybody yeah I could avoid it
um in terms of like how I dealt I think
what I really did honestly was probably
turn a lot more to like the arts it kind
of a do you play nine instruments let's
know what happened I mean I did play
music but I think I got interested in
you know films and and literature and
that have a thing that might explain you
know um you know you know what it's like
to come to this country or whatever and
you'd be different you know so you know
anything like that I think it developed
a strong sense of empathy right because
you could put yourself in other people's
shoes
I've always found like for instance that
at least in my age range someone who's
uh you know gay or lesbian they always
understood what it was like any
different ya know so I developed like an
early a sense of empathy for like the
kids who you just could tell were gay or
lesbian and I don't think I did too I
think I had no because you understand
you're like you're being treated like
you're different in a way that you
cannot control can't control there's no
ungainly and Arab in yourself or not
yeah you do it and yeah you're being
marginalized just for like being
yourself
ya know exactly and I think I I got very
I think I I was interested in you know I
mean call myself a punk rock fan that
might not be accurate but I was
interesting there but
it yeah I got into that and like metal
yeah because that was music that was
like [ __ ] the establish yeah Authority
and it never had to even really be
political but it was like the feeling
behind right yeah yeah and I did get
very interested in I was a pretty early
sixteen seventeen very interested in
current events pretty early on and Stoke
um you know so I think that kind of made
me think a little bit about like I was
very concerned about marginalized people
you know I it seemed impossible to want
to be I mean I you know someone who
wasn't in favor of gay rights you know I
mean there's a quality across the board
and I was interested early I do think I
think maybe I took a big interest in
comedy because well you know okay even
at that time comedy comedy did have
people of different backgrounds right I
mean it was mostly white male but of
course it had you know not a great
example with Bill Cosby because my show
you know he was on and it presented a
whole different way of looking at you
know after Americans right so I do think
it drew me a lot to the arts I think did
you develop a sense of humor at an early
age I think so a lot a lot of people
will say that they developed to prevent
bullying to fit in I think I was way
more not class clown I was way more
about making my friends laugh or
whatever reason I was not a class clown
I was very well-behaved guy yeah um I
don't what did I love when was it the
first in comedy was just a relief right
yeah early from all that but I think
when I was 16 or 17 18 you know I did
very well in school I got a good grades
and stuff but inside I think there was a
lot a lot of turmoil some of it maybe to
do with my identity but some of it just
to do with you know it's not fitting in
not fitting of it just being 16 yeah I
mean there is that anyway whether you
whether you're a minority or is you know
why does the drink
like yeah you can be a 16 year old kid
and like ethnically or racially or
whatever fit in but you could be
overweight you could be all kinds of you
know can't call too soon I mean it takes
very little when you're a kid to be you
know cast out five by the group of
whatever is deemed popular right exactly
and I thought happen all the time I
don't know if you felt this way because
I did feel like my parents couldn't
understand me because they never went to
high school in America right yeah and
they didn't understand like this may
sound nuts but according to my dad the
popular people at his first of all it
was mostly men right women you know it
fortunately there's a pretty at that
time especially and he was particularly
you know the popular kids were the ones
with the best grades so I know I saw
funny I didn't have anyone to really go
to with those issues I have an older
brother luckily you know what do you say
when you were like dad in my school
those are the people who are like yeah
ah you know I think another issue I was
with my parents a lot which is like if I
complained about my life is so much
easier than theirs that to complain
about anything was met with it seems
like nothing yeah well yeah because I
would say you know similar things like
you know it's it's rough in school you
don't get it and they're just like we
didn't even have electricity some guys
in here we did the classic story of I
had to walk 50 miles yeah school but you
know in those countries back then and
then like the whole moving to the States
learning another language Aaron I had to
survive here if we did that yeah you can
go make a [ __ ] friend figure it out
that was exactly the attitude and I
think that you know it did send me in a
way of thinking maybe for you too of
like you know you've had a friend come
to you with a problem that didn't seem
like a big deal but you can't ever say
you gotta like you gotta at least yeah
it's their problem in it's important
quote the TV show Ally McBeal Austin I
do but I
episode where someone said to her what
makes your problem so special and she
said well they're mine and I go I feel
that's true and I even today I would
have trouble going to my parents and
saying like you know because I do think
they always and you can't argue with it
they had no they literally had no
electricity running water they had no
doctor you know yeah they are right you
know it they came here with accents they
didn't know their language you know they
are right that they had it way I
actually heard it was interesting that
CNN commentator Van Jones you know him
you know you know obviously black guy he
went to Yale did all this really
impressive stuff and he said well
whenever he talked to his dad about like
what might be considered a
microaggression or something like that
his dad would be like what did you have
fire hoses spray that well then shut up
you know like in every culture it's sort
of like that yeah they have one yeah and
even sometimes when I hear maybe a
younger person from my culture
complaining I'm like well come on you at
least you have 50 people look like you
at your school you know yeah I'm kind of
a bad at to - so yeah I think I think I
so I sort of have it I struggle with the
whole bullying thing right now because
part of you wonders like there may be
like everyone's a way softer and like
any form of hey you know you don't fit
in or um it's considered like totally
unacceptable and I'm like I get that
bullying shouldn't be tolerated but like
is the definition that broad now like
anything counts as that and be I think
like yes bullying you know and just just
being told you don't fit in or you're
different whether it's verbal or
physical any of that it did affect me in
a negative way but it also like
strengthened me in some ways you know
like when I combine the two things when
I combine like the fact that I was able
to survive that and like learn from that
like you know they were wrong and those
were just words and all that stuff made
me a stronger person than this things I
face now where I go it's nothing it
doesn't you're yours out of your word
yeah matter like action comedy being
told you know you didn't get this job
you can't go that
not that funny yeah your this Annette
I'm just like fine doesn't matter I'll
get there
yeah you know dad came they were born of
that you know combined with my looking
back and going like if my parents could
do invaded I can do this yes I used
those two things I think that's I think
that's definitely true of me I I wonder
you know if I had a kid and they had
like whatever a funny nose and kids made
fun of it I would definitely have a lot
of I feel bad for them would I be
thinking like this will build character
someday I probably would a little bit
yeah I don't know I I guess I guess I
felt like junior high school was not
that my high school was very much like
people had cars so it was very even you
could even have to junior high was like
Lord of the Flies I mean yeah everyone's
trap [ __ ] you know small building
together yeah in my opinion junior high
was where I really had more of an issues
with bullet it's certainly more issues
bullying but yeah and itself at the
beginning of puberty yeah and your
bodies are changing and you've extra
testosterone manage and yeah
[ __ ] nightmare exam in eighth grade
were nightmares yeah that's that I would
echo that and I would say that once I
was in high school I was kind of in like
the honors class you know you were kind
of on your path and see find a friend
group yeah girl yeah wasn't so bad but
junior high was especially like PE oh oh
and like a lord of the fly I mean it was
every man every kid for himself you know
it was just brutal so I what it did
build character yeah it strengthens you
in ways but then I guess you know you
can make the argument like well what if
some kids you know
don't use that like and then pursue the
arts and become successful and happy and
bubble and some kids end up you know
being the one that like they you know
they hang themselves in their bedroom
reduce it and then you go like I get
that too and like but where do you draw
the line and like how much of how much
of that can be good and how much of it
you know it's it's impossible to tell I
mean I you're totally right because
there is going to be mean you hear about
it you're a sadly read about it you know
every now and then did killing
themselves from like online bullying you
know and yeah well this obviously we
never had that Riley's don't have that
yeah which I actually think would have
made it easier for people who maybe to
pick on people in general right I mean
yeah just look at YouTube comments in
general right so I think it would have
been worse for me to have that you know
I think yeah um I don't know what what
the answer is I guess I know I was happy
to get out of high school get out of the
yeah like was yeah and now I look back I
actually have a lot of fondness for my
hometown man everything but at the time
I was like get me out of here I hate it
here yeah but which could have just
added with being 16 right sure yeah I
think a lot of it does because yeah like
you said there wasn't you know a lot of
people were nice and supportive again
whatever and just treated you like any
other kid yeah
but um but yeah a lot of it is like you
know you're just sick anywhere you are
you're a 16 year old who doesn't know
what the [ __ ] yeah yeah yeah thoughts
coming into their mind exactly exactly
did that sense of like you know empathy
and like an injustice and liking for the
current events enough did that inform
your decision to like go into law I
think so I mean I think that being
totally honest probably would formed my
decision on the law was basically you
know I think my family was expected you
have a graduate school I the typical
often you know eating kids are labeled
as having pressure become doctors you
know I will say my dad didn't do a lot
of that because he him and I share a
dislike of like blood and guts and stuff
so he kind of got like he's not going to
want to do right surgery
that's hilarious why he didn't go to
that school because he was like I can't
take ya cutting people up I still don't
even get how people do that for a living
it's obviously a very important amazing
profession but okay so that I didn't get
a lot of pressure for that but then the
options become either a PhD and
something or medical or law school or
business school I had no interest in
finance or business really so it was
something I was naturally interesting
but I do think if I had had my way when
I was 22 if I was I was thinking to
myself I would have just um
you know I would have I went to college
in San Antonio I would have moved to
Austin which is sort of like as you know
like an hour from there yeah an hour
from there but also kind of like the
artsy creative of the town of Tech even
back then in a ninety you know every
2000s I would have moved there and just
gotten a job and tried to figure out
what I was going to do or I would have
moved to LA and done it just started out
that way she already knew Ben at 22 like
I want to do comedy and I think I did I
didn't know how to tell myself that or
my parents I really did not know until I
parents that you know yeah what a short
story I always tell people when they ask
is like it was easier to believe it or
not sound insane it was easier to go to
law school graduate practice get apart -
then did then to tell my parents did
that I had to find a way to communicate
to them
this isn't Wow you know and as one
another something that I had did have a
friend in high school you know he was um
a football player but he's only like
five six and he would complain about all
the time I mean what do you why do you
play football
because in high school football in Texas
isn't oh yeah he just said well my dad
played football my brother played
football if it's just easier to play
football than not and I was like you
know what I actually think I understand
where exactly where yeah because that's
great you know nobody wants to you don't
want to nobody wants to do something
they know will hurt their parents
feelings and make them worry right which
it definitely did and even how harder
you've got a degree and passed the bar
and the whole deal you were like I
already did all this let me just go do
comedy for awhile and I have an
obviously an amazing back-up plan they
were still like we can't bear the
thought yeah Wow I think some of it is
um you know it's also a little like I do
think my I do think
my dad is not some of the things the
arts are particularly like a big deal or
that right I think to older he's gotten
the more he's come to appreciate them
but when you grow up or you don't have
time for the art you know you don't
think of it as you know practical or
anything the only that worthwhile
honestly you know I mean if it is like a
luxury which it somewhat is you know if
you've defined being honest yeah I mean
especially like if you went to a school
where like the popular kids you know
were the ones that got good grades like
yeah yeah I mean literally that the arts
aren't yeah you know yeah and I do think
any sort of aesthetics are not like
important they're not here you can have
shitty grades but if you look really
[ __ ] cool and new about awesome bands
people are like that's the pop yeah
exactly exactly exactly so so that was
from like from a young age yeah we're
like yeah this is what matters the
numbers the grades that very much yeah
and you know it's it's you know at the
time I probably thought it was one fair
but you know when you look back you
think it's it's you know it's not so
awful I mean you know it wasn't so bad
no not at all like when you're an adult
you you realize what it really is it's
like your parents are looking out for
you they want the best for you they're
not being dicks they're not like yeah
you know watch this well you know I
would you want someone you cared a lot
about if they were like well I don't
know if I should be a lawyer a comedian
what would you tell them it's a smart
move I mean I would say like an
internment you can call this a cop-out
or not but I would say do both for a
while like go to law school yeah and do
comedy in your spare time because you
can it'll be much harder to go back and
probably get the degree yeah you know
then then um then go like you know doing
comedy because you can actually you know
dabble in it a little and yeah get the
degree and be done and then get a job
doing what the [ __ ] ever and pursue
comedy because that takes a while but
there's never like an age that's too
early or late to start you know okay
yeah I mean that's a smart answer I
agree with that I guess I mean like I
mean I've
you've seen people in showbiz it it it
can really turn people upside down you
know make them very good or very you
know bring out drug and alcohol problems
and therefore you know so I don't think
I would I would never tell my kid or
whoever someone to not do it but I would
never say like doing something practical
is stupid even if it bores you you know
because yeah it's practical you know
there's a lot of benefit to it I see it
a lot more now the one thing I could say
now that I wouldn't have been able to
say if someone asked me the same
question when I was like 21 or 23 is is
going to college and getting the degree
and doing all that stuff adds life
experience and if you want to be good at
comedy and wanted you know yeah be a
great musician or whatever it is you
will draw from those experiences even if
you're an absurdist or anything like
them you know a storyteller where I
agree but more you know obviously of
your storyteller you're talking about
your your own life um you will draw from
those things so even for that alone even
for it to help you yeah as an artist go
you know live life yeah because that
fills up you know the well you're
totally right I mean III think that's a
hundred percent true and I do think you
probably started at a younger age I
started when I was 28 doing the summer I
was 18 so yeah and I would wonder
personally if I was 18 what the hell
would I talk about I talked about being
18 yeah I did not have anything else I
talked about like I had a joke where
it's hard to meet girls because I would
essentially like you know I have to take
him over to my parents and be like you
know don't make noise or be quiet yeah
uh but don't worry because because I
would eventually somehow take him into
my room and check out this shiny new
racecar bed or whatever and if she was
horrified I would complain about how I
just got a polished and detailed or
wondering yeah yeah her presence yeah
that would do well yeah because it was
like yeah this kids are clearly 18 yeah
yeah
you know yeah probably true on some yeah
I'm sure that was the only like real
life style yeah evil could connect yeah
yeah and outside of that I did a lot of
topical material because I was her you
know very engaged in what was going on
in the news and all that stuff and I
didn't what else was I gonna do I didn't
have like you know my mind wasn't
consumed with this breakup I just went
through a job that ia you know yeah I
just gotten my first [ __ ] job
yeah you know yeah you know we're just
[ __ ] fast-food tomorrow what was that
it's frightened forever yeah but that
was it that's all I was really yeah
talking about was you know my 18 year
old worldview on like social issues and
international politics and whatever and
and you know living at home yeah that
kind of stuff so I mean I did try
stand-up in college you know and I did
it like five six times the first time
you hear this right it went pretty well
and I talked about mostly believe it or
not the TV show dukes of hazzard which I
love his a kid you know and it was just
like why do they have so many ramps in
Hazzard County you know whatever alright
a fix those doors just like you know
comedy about the logic of this show that
is obviously ridiculous and then I did
one set I would say I had a couple sets
that were not great and I did one where
I really bombed so hard and I just yeah
I didn't understand that that happens to
everybody yeah I thought well I guess
that's it for me in stand-up comedy
right you know yeah perhaps a million
right away so like a yeah over that's
really what I thought you know I think
that you and I both started before there
were podcasts and maybe more of a guide
on how you move through it no I wanted
to is no info really no info really and
I wonder if I had heard you know some
established comedian talking about how
they'd bomb they were younger if I would
have just kept doing it yeah but that
was when I was like 21 and I mean it you
know the first time he bomb it's like
yeah especially at that a you probably
bomb when you're 18 unfortunately right
I mean yeah I I just think though I was
so young in
and excited yeah it did yeah that
youthful just stupid determination I
don't think it affected me yeah yeah
like I would sum it started to as like a
year one a year yeah it's just like [ __ ]
yeah that really sucked you know yeah
things to compare it to right right we
need a five six hundred seven yeah so
yeah then it kind of did but I don't
know what it would have been like if I
started at 24 and our probably would
have felt the bomb harder you think
harder I really I don't know who knows
what I would have done from 18 to 24 I
could have become a very confident
person may be able have gone to school
and done a lot of theater or whatever so
would have been comfortable on stage and
yeah who the [ __ ] knows yeah yeah yeah
but yeah I certainly would say you know
that um if someone asked me I would say
look man stay in school for now and and
pursue the pursue the degree and like
you might still be able to do a decent
amount of comedy and the argument you
always hear is like you know but it's
better to start this kind of thing when
you're when you're younger youth is
prized in Hollywood blah blah blah and
you're like I can tell you right now I
can name a hundred people and more that
started young they had the whole thing
they looked whatever didn't work out for
them ya know you're absolutely right
about that and some it did right away
and there's a lot of in between and but
if you look at like specifically with
comedy like all the greatest comics or
you know they usually were at it for a
while I was broke when they were done
and and again largely it's because they
talk about their lives their life
experience yeah you just don't have that
[ __ ] when you're 21 you know that's what
I think yeah yeah yeah I mean I do think
like um I don't yeah I think if I'd
moved here when I was 22 I mean you grew
up in this area so I think I would have
turned right back I really I'm gonna be
able to take it but when you moved out
here you were working as a lawyer
correct well I'm not I'm not licensed in
California so I had practice law for a
couple years in DC opinion which is why
what kind of logic reckless civil
litigation
so when I came out here I did work at
law firms though but this was like legal
writing but I got I wasn't technically
couldn't sign any documents okay so so
to some degree yes to some degree now um
but yeah I came out here I got a job and
then started out at open mics basically
yeah yeah yeah and so when you practice
law there did you get a sense of like um
were you performing in a way - was it
like a different sort of when you went
on stage you're like this isn't that
weird because I was in front of people
speaking was it ever like that yeah yeah
I don't know how you see I do think I'm
actually a pretty shy person I don't
know if you are maybe you are you
sometimes you call right so I'm a pretty
shy person but I do think that public
oddly enough
shy people you know it can you know
ironically they they love public
speaking' because it's you don't have to
work to get people's attention you just
have it yeah so I actually always liked
public speaking I was never one of those
people who didn't like it in terms of
being a performance I absolutely do
think that when you think of typical
trial law like in a courtroom which I
did a couple trials it is a yeah you
know on some level I think but most
lawyer is on paper most learning is
between lawyers so there's not as much
you know you know but in terms of in
front of a jury it is plenty of famous
trial lawyers will describe it as like
what you're putting on your own play
they'll say that you know it's a hundred
percent like that Wow
most of your experience was just behind
closed doors with other lawyers a lot of
paperwork secondly oh yeah it's a lot of
writing you know it's a lot of writing
which I like you know it yeah I like I
like people writing I like writing in
general obviously but clearly um I
weren't like oh wait I got to get out of
here and go pursue comedy I can't do
this the next 30 years I think - okay so
the way I put it is like I wouldn't say
my desire to go into comedy was a
negative reaction to practice of law
okay a hundred percent it was more like
I guess if I could put it I put it this
way to myself was it was more like if I
don't do this my life will mean nothing
to me if that makes any sense I love
I then I will look back and I'll just
say what did i do on this planet you
know and yeah I don't know if it's
because I loved comedy so much I do
think I do love comedy I'm sure you do
too I think some of it was like I wanted
to test myself or something yeah I think
there's the there's that thing that like
lives in like we were saying earlier
like there's it's a part of like
American culture you know it's like
you're you got to seek your own path and
journey and go achieving radio
prove to yourself that's everywhere you
know yeah most people don't end up doing
that because I think within that people
also say well get an education work a
40-hour workweek and play the safe road
they're kind of like always conflicting
with each other you know and there's a
small window of time I think for your
average person to try that tonight I see
my window was closing because I was
pushing you know getting close to 2:30 I
was 26 27 and I'm like yeah living in DC
if I don't do this now ever so I mean
because I get in yet in a few years you
could have met who would have become
your wife had a couple kids and then
that windows just just closing you can't
just upper your family model add you
like down go be a stand-up yeah yeah so
I I think um I think I knew from the
time I was like 15 if you'd ask me what
I wanted to do I would have said
stand-up comedy that's 15 yeah I don't
think I had any like like yourself
probably had zero idea how to get into
it I thought everybody in showbiz their
dad was the president of showbiz I mean
I remember reading that come on Brian
got Late Night with Conan O'Brien right
and I was like but a little bit about
him like you went to heart I was like
whoa yeah but surely his dad is just the
guy who runs NBC because isn't everybody
want to run talk show you know whatever
I had no clue when I moved here I didn't
know what aspects I didn't know so many
things
oh yeah no knows anything yeah and it's
crazy uh when I think about it but I
guess I guess I felt that strongly about
it which is it just maybe I also thought
of it this way this is an example I've
used before when I've talked about it
which is
maybe you've seen these Sam Adams beer
ads with this guy the guy his name is
last name is cook he's the founder of it
and yeah like you know we you know the
best barley and blah blah blah whatever
right so he I'd rather talk about him
this is before I got in a comedy where
he they asked him like why you know
basically how did you get this idea to
start this because of time starting a
small brewery was was really different
it was not now there's so many micro
breweries we don't think about it but is
like one of the first and he was this
guy who was like I think a son of
immigrants and was the first person to
go to college he actually went to
Harvard he went to Harvard Business
School he had a great job at this place
called Boston Consulting Group BCG it's
like this well-paid job you made partner
you know and he decided to look at his
dreams in terms of like the way he would
look at a business which is like
percentages he said there is a literally
0% chance I'll be happy doing this even
if there's a point zero zero zero zero
zero one chance I could do this brewery
and it could make me happy that's
actually the smarter thing to do that's
actually kind of the way I assess it I
said if I was the chief - if someone
said you can have whatever dream law job
you want you can have a billion dollars
but you can never even take your shot at
comedy I would have said no what I was
being true to myself not trying to
please my parents or my community yeah I
would have said yeah but I just really
feel like this urge to see if I'm any
good at it or something
you know I don't know I that's the way I
thought of it and I felt like if it was
that extreme I should do it because yeah
that is very extreme feels that way and
yeah if this scenario is everything
almost anybody could imagine and want
yeah
or take a shot at this bout a meal I
like making it I mean just taking my
didn't try you it it felt so core to my
sense of life's purpose I guess for me
here where Dee's unit comes from because
your family by like they never encourage
that sort of like go explore your inner
desires and be yourself if they were
very much like play it safe jobs that
are good so where do you think that I
think so
probably came you know it's interesting
I don't know if this is true but someone
told me that someone asked Johnny Cash
like how did you become Johnny Cash and
he said well probably low self-esteem
and only the kind of low self-esteem
your dad can give you and I guess I feel
like that is a little bit applicable to
me on some I felt like your dad gave you
those him just listen I think so and I'm
not even on purpose but it just happened
that way and I think that from like what
tough love that kind of thing tough love
probably also like nothing was ever good
enough right
more from like let's play out his dad
was to him it probably drove my dad
pretty hard to write I think that I had
to I think it planned a lot to do with
like feeling like if I can do something
really hard then I could feel good about
myself and it can answer a lot of these
issues I have of yourself I don't think
I even knew it then I feel like people
who are generally confident don't have
that like come from looking younger age
don't have that desire to like you know
pad their self-worth not impact like the
building void where self-worth would be
because I know I had that when I was
younger I was just like I'm not I'm not
cool I'm not popular I'm not smart I'm
not fun I'm not attractive I'm not all
these things and I was like and then I
guess maybe that's why people are drawn
to the arts because you're like look at
this person excelling at this thing
under a spotlight adoring fans yeah and
I don't know if you feel this way it
probably applies your pride most people
I know who are good it's in it which is
like I feel like the best parts of
myself are on display when I'm doing
stand-up comedy like I feel like if
someone's gonna respect me yeah they saw
me do stand-up date they would respect
me you know yeah that's how I feel about
it you know yeah whereas I already I'm
very quiet that area answers to that
question because I get that a lot people
go how could you be how do you have
social anxiety like you're on stage yeah
yeah yeah but I've been doing that for a
long time I've worked hard I know how to
do it yeah and I'm at home there way
more than a room full of [ __ ] stress
that's exactly how I feel and I do feel
like I mean I kind of it I mean I wet at
the time if you'd asked me when I moved
here why I was doing I probably would
have made a argument about like maybe
somewhat so satisfactory but like being
like I'm being courageous I'm being
brave whatever when I look back I think
how desperate was I sort of like yeah to
answer some of these things that were
inside me you know I must have been so
it's so insane to do that when you have
I had a job there credible right health
insurance you know it's so not you know
so yeah some people argue that it's like
you know people with big egos come do
this and I think some people do it
because the complete lack of one I think
so I think most people will fill a void
I think most people do it for the latter
reason yeah I think and I do think that
ego sometimes comes later yeah and I
think a lot of people who do all kinds
of things that are I think ambition can
come from trying to make yourself feel
good about yourself for a lot of people
you know even like Abraham Lincoln was
people think was basically like that you
know really his dad was very awful to
him and he was this hick and he really
wanted to yeah make something of himself
to prove he was worth something you know
or whatever all all kinds of people I
think are liked I think a lot of
politicians are like you know Bill
Clinton had this ambition that came from
like his dad was yeah bad you know off
of him so I I do think and some of the
people I know who are the most steady
people who they do seem to have from an
early age relative competence you know
the kind who become you know choose a
steady profession and I could sew and is
fine around here but when I was a kid I
thought everybody wanted to be a great
artist a great actor the right side or
whatever big thing actually the very
small percentage clearly do
yeah I think you know most people just
want to have a good life for the family
and yeah have as much fun as possible
and that's about it they don't want to
like start a company or write write
write a novel you know or anything you
know I don't think yeah I think yeah the
large majority are like you know totally
fine I mean that that's great sure no I
mean I know the second thing I wanted to
be after like a comedian or ever was
like it'd be cool to be a teacher okay
because I had such a big problem with
the way things were in school with life
how little the teachers cared and how I
just saw these problems with it I so I
was like my anger went towards you know
that next rose like I could [ __ ] do
this better teacher should be like this
and did it yeah and I think I think it
would be fun I think I'd be good at it
and that's as far as you can get right
from like under a spotlight trying to
make tons of money and be fast teachers
are underpaid undervalued under
everything yeah and I came right after
comedian/actor door like wow okay yeah
which I still can't really explain that
but yeah so yeah I don't think there's
anything wrong with like good noble
honest hard work that is out of the
spotlight no I am not really creative
although you know you can be creative at
the answer but yeah yeah it makes me
wonder like now that like you wondered
like second generation and third
generation like ethnic families like
because if you would think like for a
lot of years a everything was very white
driven you know entertainment all that
sort of stuff and you wonder if kids
grew up not even thinking to do that
because in the family and in the culture
it's like it's not a repression for the
Arts is not there it's like look we got
here we're in this country you're going
to do this and that's how our entire
[ __ ] family has been through never
and ever but you know with the
generation that disease is from me and
you and and then the one after that you
would think like more and more will
pursue it and get into it in a time
where there's just more room for it
anyway
and I do think I don't know about you
but I I you obviously wanted to put it
but I did somewhat hesitate thinking
well there's no one like me on TV why
would I bother try to be on TV I
we thought you know our nose from all
sides from in in the home of the family
TV yeah everywhere yeah yeah but you
wonder if now they'll just be more and
more I think there are more more
comparatively yeah eating convenience
for sure I mean I'm always mildly
shocked yeah and like I said it earlier
I was talking about the White House I
mean again to me that was like shocking
that that could happen yet I think maybe
the younger people is like well I
wouldn't it
you know we tell you know we're here and
we're trying and working hard and but
I'm just like oh that's businesses so
out-of-date it doesn't thing like that
but they clearly do know some degree
right so I don't know even like
something that you know I you know as
you mentioned I'm a writer and I I never
thought I'd to write a script about it
was personal or something or about my
own culture because I thought who would
be interested right
it was my honest answer like who would
be interested in whatever like an Indian
version of The Cosby Show or something
and then now there's you know just like
the fresh off the boat or what you know
and I'm like and now people keep telling
me you should be doing that that's what
people are interested in so I I do think
the business changed quite a bit in the
time you and I have been in in terms of
that for the better you know yeah in
terms of diversity but I don't I I do
think that I'm definitely old enough to
have come from a generation of you know
Indian people who just never saw him and
like them on TV it was like mind-blowing
when you did you know is like I can't
believe this you know so and it still is
when I see like I mean it's probably so
routine to someone who is younger than
me funny but when I see like Sanjay
Gupta or so I'm just like wow oh that's
funny that still is there with you it I
think it always will be you know he'll
mind-blowing and and you know I do
remember seeing like you know she had
obviously been on the office but I saw a
billboard for Mindy Kaling show me when
it was coming out yeah project I was
just like you're like what I mean it
just caught me like I can
believe this I guess like the equivalent
of the closest thing to that would be
like if you were from a really small
town somewhere not or nowhere Virginia
said wherever Idaho yeah and someone
from your small town made it oh yeah
you're everywhere why you little yeah oh
yeah I think for white people like they
would sit there and go we never would
have a male yeah oh yeah at a town of
1,900 people you know and Chris Pratt
came out of that yes a guy yeah yeah
that would be the equivalent I got IP so
yeah
every time you see an Indian person yeah
like what are the odds what do I never
let about but now you know again it's a
different world different show is
different for the better I just think
like and I do think that influenced my
parents to they were like it's great and
all you're interested in this but who no
one's why would they ever make anything
about you you know like why would you be
of any use to showbiz you know right
they're thinking too in there you know
which isn't totally impractical or dumb
you know so it is it is like I still
have it that like I said I still like
wow like I can't believe it you know and
I was I was even so this was week just
the White House response was just like
two hours ago I was still standing there
going like I cannot believe was raining
guys back here who worked on this thing
like I couldn't believe it even though
it probably isn't that big a deal at all
you know so I don't know if it's I guess
it's just age or where I'm from yeah
generation that's have to think yeah I
think I think it probably is but that's
great I think that that it's good the
things of are moving that that quickly I
guess now yeah and I don't know long
enough but you know I guess yeah it's
good that they are yeah and when I got
into stand-up I didn't like try to like
not where my attention it just wasn't
what I was interested in talking about
yeah likewise you know and whenever I do
talk about I'd evolved into what I'm
doing now which is I'm quite serious
yeah and I'm nothing funny to say about
it except but I'm very interested in it
obviously you know yes you are I feel
like that yeah that's where it starts
because I'm now talking about it a
little
yeah but I for very really I never did
and the very little I did I'm like I'm
not gonna be a [ __ ] monkey about it
and just go like you know we're really
really yeah yeah disgusting to me I
don't care for that either when I see
that I'm just like you [ __ ] sellout
like how dare you boil down your people
to like a joke about the food they eat
or the way it's like yeah [ __ ] out yeah
you know I mean the other thing I
thought that maybe you thought - I mean
again I'm not using a great example but
Bill Cosby would show that his the
groupies from his behavior you know not
counting you know right you know you
just show that you're a person yeah and
that that that was for my my I did have
that thought early on alone rather than
get up on stage and do accents to talk
about curry or whatever right show you
know I'm a person where somebody like
just an example you know Hassan or maybe
you know her econ abala day they weren't
on their sleeve they talk about it very
directly maybe somewhat similar to
someone like Richard Pryor so you know
they're yeah
they're going to hit it head on and go
at it and talk about it whereas my I was
trying to do anything frankly what I was
trying to do was get a writing job
number one all right but after that I
was I guess in a bigger goal might have
been yeah you know people will see that
whatever yeah you know and my mom always
said to me early on issues like you're
probably going to be one of the first
people to look at you that anyone so you
always have to have manners because you
know what I mean like yeah in a place
like Arlington if you're even if you're
seven or if you're 16 you know how many
people are going to interact with with
an Indian person so you want to it kind
of puts a pressure on you of like you're
basically representing like 1.2 billion
people so high honors you know and I
think she meant it I think it was a good
lesson you know of like it just made me
have manners frankly but you know yeah
you know I think she was right in a town
like that people aren't going to be
exposed to right you know what yeah if
their one experience like because it did
yeah you didn't want to get give that
reputation and I and I'm sure you are
often the first you know Lebanese
American person some many people around
has interacted with a lot of people
don't know that it's surprisingly still
to this day this is go what where or
what is that like how do you not even
know it's a con right like if you don't
know where it is on a map yeah yes I'm
doing like bits kind of about that you
know my experiences we have that sort of
thing you know and like people
questioning how American I am and that
kind of thing not not in very overt ways
but yeah I'm approaching like that the
same way I guess like Hassan and hurry
do it you know yeah they get they but
they go way more direct and if they do
and I like the way they approach it like
I do interesting and they're not doing
the you know you know we Indians over
there they're not very or whatever the
[ __ ] you know yeah which is great the
way it should be done that's the way to
inform people like hey I'm just like you
and I'm not in certain ways but I'm
still you know yeah like yeah the food
we ate is different bubble and whatever
way you're going to do it that I think
is the most like engaging and
interesting way because the other way
you know people like to tell themselves
like no you know when you bring humor to
it everyone understands ego no because
in the Mexican comic makes a joke about
like and then I stabbed him like you
know or whatever ya know are with our
[ __ ] tamales or something like that
sometimes you see people like see they
do do that you know yeah doing the
opposite yeah no that's absolutely makes
me crazy yeah I mean it's also not that
surprising either right if you didn't
mean so much stand-up yeah I have it
yeah that that yeah for a long time I
want I just like I went I just went too
hard in the other direction I'm like I'm
never gonna mention it and that was like
it was deliberate or it was what you
felt it was deliberate because I just
like thought it was just such cheap
comedy you know and I'm like I'm so much
more than that stuff like I don't sit
there and live this I don't filter
everything through being well that's
that's also people ask me how come I
never talk about my background or there
also has to be how come I never to have
I haven't been a lawyer on stage
right you know more back you know it's
basically pretty pretty third it's not
like I'm addressing I'm not personal
anyway right but and I was like well I
don't want to be have that one badge
like that's the air comedian that's the
union kid me you know I didn't want to
limited idea I guess I I did have that
quite often about like well I don't want
to just be that guy right but I have had
comedians I won't say who but some
pretty successful ones even say to me
well you know this business they just
put you in a box and your problem is
that put you in that Indian guy box
anyway and then when you don't address
it people are like why am I gonna dress
it at all you know this is more like 10
years ago
but ok yeah you know you know I'm
talking about they never tell you like
you should play it up because I've heard
that a lot right I read a lot the guys
we play into that [ __ ] that's hot right
now they're looking for the and I'm like
but I mean and I get where they're
coming from but those are usually people
that if you look at their comedy they're
going for the dollar two or they're
doing for the most obvious thing I know
I've never heard the most honest
comedians that are just really doing it
for themselves to like you know achieve
high art in their own guard ever say
that kind of thing yeah they never say
yeah you know play up this or do
something that is disingenuous you know
to you they never say that
they do what makes you happy you know
right what's honest to you and people
will connect with that Lee you'll
eventually find what it is that's
definitely what I what I think is true
but I do think like if you're viewing it
from my perspective of somewhat casting
agent or something yeah you know you're
just never going to shake they're going
to say is an Indian guy right they're
never going to not say like is Raj the
human being right they're always going
to filter it through that which is
totally reasonable and they would do it
to a white person too right so I do
think like there is that box you get put
into yeah I'm sorry maybe I'm maybe I'm
crazy or something but in my head I'm
just like well I'm just gonna get to a
point where like it doesn't like they
wouldn't think I mean is different I
guess for me too because I get cast so
multi-ethnic they can just go for some
manual I am but I think if you get to a
point where they see you first you know
your career
like you've defined yourself as a
comedian to weather like that's not a
guy who can play an Indian that's Raj
Desai and then he can play whatever you
know maybe like Aziz an example yeah
I've got to that level yeah yeah where
he would like to hit cool yeah yeah dude
like the human giant thing was just
these cool guys doing yeah funny weird
[ __ ] yeah um and I think he had it built
into or he was like I'm not playing
these characters you know yeah yeah cuz
I'm sure what happened after that when
offers were coming in for all this stuff
yeah or auditions I'm sure a lot of them
were you're this cab driver but it's
hilarious you're this yeah you know he
won this restaurant and I'm sure it was
I mean I I I mean I actually keep a lab
coat in my trunk in case I get a doctor
audition or a scientist audition or
something that's so funny so I mean I
have been through that a little bit not
I've never been bets or Sinatra but yeah
so that's really funny yeah I don't know
have you ever had someone an audition
ask you to do an accent of sometimes it
wasn't like British or something was
like meant to text you for your maybe
once or twice when I was younger but
like I I don't have I think I did it now
it's just like I think I'll do it up or
I just bombed the audition or something
so I'm like I don't want to do I've had
it multiple times and but my other
question to me when I've asked myself is
it even people do talk like that I mean
people do have you know indian morning
in have an accent
is it even bad or racist I don't even
know I guess it's the gender of the
character it boils down to that way yeah
instead you go even more hard line on it
they go I get that they do but the roles
are so overwhelmingly stereotypical yeah
like until they start doing the other
thing I just refused to do this because
yeah more people refuse the more likely
they'll start writing characters like
yeah
Aziz is I'm alright right right yeah you
know and then yeah because there are
sometimes you do get into a cab that's
being driven by an hour meaning guy I
hear in any idea or whatever those are
best real life but someone was using the
example once that like
um you know there are roles for black
people but you like it shows like The
Wire or whatever like that show is all
Mona all but like 98% black and you're
like yeah but you know I've black
friends ago like yeah but why do they
have to be shows about drug dealers and
gangs and criminals yeah yeah so balance
the scales I guess a little bit hot you
know have a guy that is Indian who's
just an accountant or a chef or like
yeah at a place that's not any niceties
right right right right right oh yeah
yeah I totally grin
I do think looking back I will say I
mean I voted to the media had a big
impact on what I saw on TV had a big
impact on what yeah how I saw myself
yeah in terms of am i American or not
and absolutely this and yeah it had that
effect on me too I thought like I I to
me it was all the way down to like white
families are happier the homes are
better the homes are happier the homes
are this because I don't know I don't
know your how I will say this money so
family life depicted on like full house
people are very affectionate right they
say I love you / - hugs that's not the
way anything are yeah you know they're
not that physically affectionate and I
think that had a big impact on me - I
thought I was maybe being I neglected or
something when I probably was just
totally normal for my culture you know
and they showed it that you know people
any people show affection in a different
way like yeah I mom would make your
favorite food you know she wouldn't
necessarily make a big scene about you
coming home or what you know that's how
she would show you right I'd your home
or whatever or another one people point
out was like like a lot of white
families are more often than not like
have really intimate conversations about
like things that ethnic families would
never brush at us and daily yeah how the
[ __ ] could you talk to your mom yeah
Earl you're dating now yeah yeah I mean
I totally I I mean my dad did not give
me any sort of puberty talk yeah I
didn't get and that's actually probably
pretty rare for where you and I went to
school right but if you ask me now what
I wouldn't now on my dad I would do it
for my son of course but yeah it would
have just been so insanely awkward I
didn't know it's awkward enough with
people who are used to that happening or
whatever or had it happened for
themselves but no way I mean you're
telling okay that's it that okay that's
I'm not shocked or anything but like
that's the way I grew up too was not
nobody talked about anything into
matters yeah you just isn't crazy and
you just didn't do it you know if you
had something like I would never to this
day tell my parents I felt depressed or
something never yeah my parents wouldn't
understand I would if I was like I have
depression anxiety disorder all these
would end like so you're sad like you're
feeling sad about something like they
would think it was circumstantial like
yeah like you have this like chemical
imbalance in your head from a young age
that yeah damn it let you get out of bed
some days and feel that you're with yeah
life's worth living or whatever because
they didn't just didn't grow up but now
that I think and I and I do think I
threw it to America in like 1950 it was
the same for people you know all you
know white people then and they felt
like they're you know they couldn't
admit they like I just read Bruce
Springsteen's autobiography it was good
I'm a huge Springsteen fan so I loved it
but other Grady alikum - yeah I mean
it's really interesting but you know he
says that there was always rinsing out
uh darkness on the edge of town Hammond
- okay cool that's awesome yeah I love
darkness but you know he had all these
and actually reading about his home life
did remind me a little of mine where you
know in the 1960 you just didn't you
didn't say dad I feel depressed if he'll
be yeah you just didn't do it and I was
like okay I get that whereas like al I
think a lot of people now reading that
with Selleck ancient or something
yeah you know so yeah that is where like
I think like cultures that are
traditionally looked at is more like
buttoned up or conservative in those
parts of the world like people think
like well they don't discuss their
feelings or they don't like you know
yeah women do this too that yeah you go
back in American culture not even that
far there's a lot of similarity you know
what like every time I'm arranged
marriages back then you mostly married
someone in your town yeah it wasn't like
you were that you had to get the
approval yeah yeah it wasn't arranged
marriage but it was like somewhat
similar and limited and if like so there
I've talked to friends of mine that grew
up in the South who like if they go home
now around the age of 30 people are like
you're critical how are you not man how
are you not married
and you're like well they're American
and white and from here yeah but their
family's looking down to where they
think they're like lesbians yeah I
believe that so you know I you know it's
it's it's comforting I guess in some
level for you or me and you realize
you're just part of this migration this
country and everything Indians everybody
but I would like to think that I would
be me and my brother are more likely to
talk about our feelings or whatever you
know same with me mine and I'm more
likely to go to my mom about my feelings
just like was women a little more yeah
into that egg I would never and I think
I care more often when you're growing up
young [ __ ] hits the fan when you're a
kid you're like I got beat up in school
or my grades this or I feel like that
you go cry to them yeah dad's at work
and and I gotta work and my dad would
just say those aren't problems honestly
I think it would be his general attitude
so and not to dump on the guy he did a
great job it is what he had but you know
so I I do think I would try to be a
little bit more I guess Americanized or
westernized about raising my kid you
know while you're bothering you you know
not like yeah yeah I agree I mean I grew
up around that I guess but I did what I
saw like full house or something like it
just seemed like people have families
like this where they ask people what's
wrong with their day and
talk to them about I mean I was just and
it did have a huge impact on me I don't
know if I thought I guess I don't want
to wear something you were saying you
you felt like you came from a bad family
because it wasn't like I don't know no
well I just wore I meant like there they
were like closer in the sense that it
like you see on TV so you in my head
their homes were happy or were happier
and more like that yeah dad's like took
more interest in their friends I think I
think part of that stem from like my
parents were so disconnected from
American pop culture that I couldn't be
like like why hey what about this rock
and roll album or let's go play a
hatchery cuz you know did these at work
all day every day yeah and when he's at
home he's not like trying to figure out
what's cool on MTV anything so like a so
in that sense I thought like wow those
white families are like probably they
got it going on over there like that I
guess I did think that
thanks for watching The Scindia together
and like they're doing more things that
I wished I yeah you know was connected
to school with my friends and with my
family yeah but then in reality when you
when you grow up and when you go to
those homes and you're just like oh
there's plenty of problems there a lot
of the homes are oh yeah broken and
whatever since so their parents also
don't take an interest because they're
busy working or just being shitty
parents yeah or anything in between you
know so yeah yeah there are certain
things you think and it's sort of
related to like you know how I thought
things were in the south or wherever
there are stereotypes you have you know
oh wow
and it comes from the fact that you know
everyone's in their corner going they're
probably like this yeah and then you
never meet in the middle and right so
you grow up bigger up now you know you
have like yeah I have friends from like
I mean all walks of life you know yeah I
will say like out of anything I've done
stand-up comedy introduced me to a lot
of different title yeah I know it's
often gets a rap for being on diverse
that may very well be true but you're
going to meet people yeah from just
different parts of the country different
different ethnics different parts of the
world even you know so yeah and somebody
just different
kinds of people like people that I know
I would if I didn't do comedy I would
not be friends with righty a few times
we have two absolutely true as well yeah
for me probably more if I mean because
like once I was in law school and on
that path I was only going to meet other
professional oh yeah yeah you know yeah
I mean I have friends would like who've
been jail like it's local Rimmel's
before then friends that were lawyers
before they were a friend that was a
doctor Matt Eisen you know I didn't talk
that much anymore but like he was
looking I remember he was not working
yeah yeah um oh yeah and it just runs it
just runs the gamut but yeah it isn't a
lot of ways incredibly diverse it is I
would say leave socioeconomically yeah I
want to say comment on the male-female
divides like that bit so economically
you got open mic you can find something
with the Harvard someone who's a lawyer
and every drop out of time yeah yeah
yeah you know yeah yeah so it is it's
interesting I did feel that immediately
when I got into this I go wow like yeah
people are really from all types of
different backgrounds you know yeah it's
just it's it's like immediately exciting
like god there's so many different
feeling yeah any questions you know you
learn a lot of stuff that you otherwise
wouldn't have you know oh yeah um ya
know which is hopefully the aim of this
thing yeah we've been we've been every
time I tell myself an hour hour we've
been talking for two hours
really oh okay well hope that's a good
thing you know I think it is I think I
didn't notice really I just carry
battery life but I can I didn't notice I
was very engaged okay good it's very
interesting let's go yeah anything else
you want to UM no no no I used to have
like a questions yeah where I was like I
want to ask people this when I first
like was was coming up with what to do
but I'm like everyone's so different
that like I don't know that a lot of
like the questions were you know would
apply like one thing I thought before I
started was like you know if I talk to
people that grew up in certain parts of
the country and is again a holdover of
what I imagined right what I I bet
they'll have stories about not fitting
in or getting bullied or this is that I
mean you don't really have any of maybe
a couple
yeah but it didn't like consume your
childhood or right right or whatever and
if you had a pill I talked to them elect
yeah a few things here and there and but
not really you know yeah he-man where I
had on he grew up in Seattle rep
regressive liberal right right the whole
thing but those are like and so that
kind of like scratch that question off
for the most part I maybe touch on and
like yeah that's not there let's go to
other side yeah but that already has
been like a really cool thing I'm
discovering like now how accepting a lot
of people all you know no I would say
yeah the majority of people that might
be were able label like I mean I grew up
in a really Republican been most
somewhere pretty nice yeah I mean
obviously it wasn't perfect you know
yeah when I look back on it I always say
like I would also say this there's a lot
of you angel Christians in my community
and I know they some they do get a bad
rap or maybe being close-minded
sometimes about gay marriage that type
of things but those people are they just
treat people well yeah and they will be
welcoming to you no matter who you are
yeah just because they think they're
that's how you should treat people you
know right I did have I do have a soft
spot for them as well as yeah yes cool
yeah yeah I think a lot of this was um
we already went through anyway just sort
of happens in the conversation and he
sort of um the one that I had this
doesn't apply to you is do you ever ever
desire to go back and live and in the
country he came from your parents came
from but like your [ __ ] life was I
guess that answer would be do you want
to go back to Arlington you hire in
Arlington you know yeah well you know I
have a lot more finance or Texas now
than I did I would totally I would
probably live in Austin you know yeah
there is a charm at that state there so
Texas about every day are very it's its
own cultural um yeah like so I love
that's one of my favorite states okay
yeah it really is I found that people
often have a strong opinion on it if you
say you're like from Missouri people are
like they don't really have a strong
opinion with a lot of times the opinion
is very negative about Texas yeah all
like because
Texas goes out of their way to have a
very strong personality they didn't in
anything that has a different
personality a pinion I love it the
people a larger-than-life very proud of
their [ __ ] [ __ ] and and that leads to
like yeah cool I mean the food is like
the [ __ ] best yes chicken-fried steak
has always been something I thought was
hilarious
yeah and barbecue and it means the way
they do it it's like you go to a
barbecue joint and there's just sick
[ __ ] smokers going and parking a lot
I'm like they go crazy with it and then
it's among videos weed I've ever had in
my life yeah yeah no I mean I I got a
lot more fun as for once I which I think
happens a lot of people I guess you've
lived in this area premature whole life
so but you know I definitely follow the
Texas Rangers and the cowboy yeah I was
a kid I was like I'm so tired of
football and now I am interested in my
high school football team which I could
believe Oh funny did yeah so can I Drive
and driving to a football game listening
to Bruce Springsteen yeah yeah Rogers
side story that is yeah yeah that's
funny all right
or at two hours okay call it we did it
thanks for doing this thanks Jeremy ah
no it was um working people find you uh
probably if you google Roger decide
you'll find me Raj and then des AI or my
Twitter is at underscore Raj decide all
right JD Instagram you know I'm not on
its game now one of the few holdouts I
am I would tie I think getting on
Twitter was enough from the guy uh
website anyone can go to uh I have a
tumblr site that is actually a web site
yeah which so probably Twitter is the
best way to find me okay
there you have it underscore ROG decide
find on Twitter you're very funny on
Twitter too
oh thank you
[Music]
and then watch if you haven't seen yet
the White House Correspondents Dinner
that can like be found and in its
entirety yeah check it out that's right
it's really good it's really funny and
if you forgot from two hours ago he
wrote on it yeah it's so much has been
disgusting we got a story
yeah um you wrote on any was great thank
so again get up you write and then I
will see you guys next week